yeah so so crystals crystals going to be
playing through or helping us through
this this evening now we wanted to lead
off actually with a little bit of sort
of YouTube news ish and there's a very
good reason for this to be a for that
ish and this is a YouTube restricted
mode so it's a thing that everybody's
talking about talking about these days
and if you're not if you don't know what
it is
so YouTube's restricted mode is a mode
that YouTube has the restricts content
and in theory this is supposed to be a
lockdown uh you know I have handed my
iPad off to a toddler you know a
five-year-old and they're browsing you
and we really just want to play it safe
and play it SuperDuper safe and the
reason why people are getting into
getting worked up over it
over this is that the algorithms and the
processes that are determining what gets
restricted and what doesn't are
disproportionately targeting LGBT
content regardless of actual content and
actual tone that's simply being
identifiably LGBT is enough to consider
something worthy of being restricted and
that's a problem that is absolutely a
problem um however the thing to keep in
mind so now here's the thing is
restricted modes actually been around
for over a year they rolled it out in
December of 2015 so you may be asking
why is it just now getting exposure and
that's because it was rolled out to
almost no fanfare and people just kind
of started to notice recently so it is a
feature that's just kind of lurking
there it's not heavily used it has been
around for a while that's not an excuse
that's just like hey this is kind of
some worthy history here is it's like it
has been around for a while and people
are just kind of now noticing and
so it's not that this is a new product
it's just that people are finally sort
of realizing what it is that this thing
does and and that's kind of thing so
that's what the that's that's what
you're hearing about YouTube's
restricted mode right now is the the
problem there is that it it is treating
LGBT content if it is identifiably LGBT
it seems to automatically get elevated
in terms of its odds of being restricted
now occurring and the other ways
actually patient evils automatically
sexual exactly exactly and sort of
extending from that there's also
problems with the there is no appeals
process there's no way to tell if your
stuff has been restricted or not like if
you're on the dashboard if I'm on my
dashboard I can't see which of mine are
invisible and restricted mode I need to
go manually check that by opening a
window putting it in restricted mode
viewing my channel and then making a
note of what doesn't show up so like
really up there with YouTube's history
of being really creator friendly yeah
you know so so there's no way to tell if
your stuffs been restricted there's no
way to appeal the process the guidelines
on what is or like how things get
restricted and what they consider should
be restricted are opaque and and it kind
of goes back to a general like YouTube
not adequately providing the the
granular controls that that users need
and now if you were in H Ballmer guys
stream if you're watching these Ballmer
guys stream on Friday this is going to
be a repeat of some of the stuff I said
there but one of the things that YouTube
really kind of needs to do and one of
the problems that they run into with
building to tools like restricted mode
is that they don't do an adequate job of
providing granular control for the
sorts of age restriction for the like
age identifying like the target age
identification of content so what they
do have right now one of the one thing
that they do have is you can flag a
video as contains mature contents which
puts it behind you know a voluntary age
gate and then you need to be signed in
in order to in order to pass that age
gate and the functionality of that were
like the the effectiveness of that is is
open to debate as with any sort of
voluntary age gate you know it's it
doesn't take kids very long for them to
get savvy enough to know how to lie
about being 18 but you know its its
assistant and it does like it's it's the
very least like something approaching a
sort of gatekeeper and for people who
like really do not want to like
personally stumble on you know a I don't
know movie trailer like if they don't
want to see red band movie trailers
because they really do not want to
engage with that content then it does
help them so there is a theoretical
person out there who is going to use it
in good faith and it's going to help
them do whatever with their life and the
problem here is that the moment you flag
something as age restricted it becomes
ineligible for monetization like hundred
percent you know even even red band
trailers don't show on restricted
content you you cannot monetize our
restricted video a you know a mature
content video so so this means that
creators then no matter how edgy they
get if they run their channel off of ad
revenue they have an incentive to not
ever age restrict their content or flag
it for age restriction and the problem
here is that you know it doesn't matter
if the content is actually over the line
like they're not going to pull back
they're just going to kind of hope the
only time I've seen people like really
voluntarily age restrict something is
when they know that it's like really far
out there and they would rather just
preemptively give up on the ad revenue
rather than risk the Community
Guidelines violation wait so the way
you're explaining it though that makes
it sound like they only want to
advertise like okay so so you can't
advertise to kids even if the ads are
kid based though like that doesn't make
any sense well so you you can advertise
to yeah okay because you're right you're
right this is this is happening to
something else by not laying users like
actually get more granular that it you
pretty much only have to age restriction
settings right now which is the the
bottom is the opaque restricted mode
which no one really understands how it
works from seemingly ads stuff at random
and definitely false Flags a lot of
stuff that it shouldn't end and indicate
some back-end
algorithmic biases that definitely need
to be interrogated so you have that at
the low end you have I gave my iPad to a
toddler and then you have porn but crazy
you know you've got like Clayton cubits
stuff and I mean don't get me wrong I
think Clayton qubit is a fantastic
artist like vo artist but like let's
let's be honest it's not porn it's HBO
that kind of a situation like you've
really only got those two extremes so
there isn't anything in between and this
actually works against YouTube's
interest because if they let me flag all
my stuff like let's say it's like I
could still be viable for monetization
but I I flagged everything is like look
this is this is thirteen plus this is
fifteen plus we aren't going to get
particularly raunchy you know it's not
going to go way out there I don't
actually
use like any profanity in the in the
main videos but we are talking about you
know mature content and and I use that
and be actual like actual mature content
like we're talking about death and
morality and you know some some weighty
subjects at times by still having that
viable for monetization I have willingly
given YouTube information that they can
take to advertisers to help accurately
target ads and the thing is is this kind
of thing is is standard on television
like every single TV set TV show has a
very tightly uh you know a focused
statement on who's the target audience
like on their Democrat on their
demographic targets and you do by and
large simply reverse engineers those to
a degree that is you know effective like
that they basically say like okay logged
in users who have voluntarily given us
their information we can reverse
engineer the age you know who's watching
it based on that but you know I don't
know they're they're kind of missing out
by not taking producers word on who on
what audience they're targeting right
and they're actually actively like
trying to keep people from doing that by
taking away that incentive ization of
monetization of their videos like
they're actively saying we don't want
you to tell us what's in your videos
because if you do we're not going to pay
you anymore yeah exactly I mean the
thing is is that there's no reason like
at the end of the day there's no real
reason to restrict fully restrict
monetization even on mature content
because if you think about it like
YouTube will show the occasional like
they'll get the occasional red band
trailer campaign and you know you think
about it like evil dead evil Dead's red
band trailer like absolutely they're
going to do a they're going to do an ad
buy on mature content videos if that's a
possibility
that's getting them right to their
target audience so there's just a couple
different says there's a couple
different things that they that they
need to do in that regard they need to
give users more more tools to help state
like who is who am i targeting which is
in turn going to help them better target
videos it's going to help them just do
their thing better and they need to
remove the opacity they need to just how
oblique and impenetrable it is on the
restricted the restricted side of things
well and not to like totally gank you in
a slightly different direction but so am
I correct in assuming though that this
is but whatever their algorithm is is
also taking kind of taking cues from
like are they letting users flag other
people's content anyway so that's yes
okay so there's already a entire system
in place for reporting content like that
you can you can report inappropriate
content and if enough of those reports
come in one and two things will happen
like if it's too far out there like
let's say you actually put up like you
know animal abuse that's straight up
against the against the community code
of conduct and so that'll just get taken
down and your account will probably get
deleted but let's say it's just like you
didn't you know you there's some nipples
you know you got some titties in your
video and that's not technically we are
the male nipples are female nipples the
female nipples you've got some female
okay I have that needs to be restrictive
so so that is not a severe violation of
the community guidelines so your your
account isn't going to get restricted
but the the video if enough reports come
in saying like hey this is mature
content then that video is going to get
automatically flagged for mature content
now here's where those overlap is that
it seems from what we can tell
that regardless of the content of video
if enough people report it even if on
review it does not get escalated it's
still going to be considered
controversial and that controversial
flag in turn basically becomes a like
Auto
like okay you are now invisible in
restricted mode and the reason we can
tell this is because we're looking at a
bunch of like the channels of like zoe
quinn and a number of other people who
have been the target of hate campaigns
like we know they have stalkers who who
will maliciously report literally
everything these people ever put up and
so stuff that's just like hey i'm going
to sit here and i'm going to talk about
programming in arduino and it does not
like none of the metadata none of the
tags none of the title none of the
nothing about it even suggests anything
remotely close to what would be under
any definition restricted v they don't
swear in it nothing but because no doubt
4chan [ __ ] have gone through and
flagged every single video on that
channel have reported every single video
on that channel as inappropriate that
programming and our do we know video is
now controversial and so it's not
visible in restricted mode huh yeah see
that's a problem i bro yeah and there's
no and there's no appeals process well
in it yeah it kind of goes along with i
know you talked about this a long time
ago about um you know the the malicious
like takedown notices like oh this is
copyright material or you're using this
phrase in the name of your video and you
know we copyrighted that phrase now like
it's that same problem like you're
taking away the money stream you can't
get it back and as you're saying now you
know there's not really a review process
if it goes to this extent yeah yeah so
so that's that's kind of the the
situation with
restrict mode that's what you're hearing
about that's what people are talking
about that's why people are upset is
because it's clearly easily gamed by
malicious actors it's clearly false
flagging or like elevating certain types
of content like any content to deal that
even passingly mentions LGBT at all like
just the the existence of LGBT is
considered an aggravating factor and a
bunch of other things like I mean and
the the hilarious thing so this is a
hilarious thing as the the free speech
warriors out there so-called free speech
warriors are not particularly concerned
because it's hurting their enemies so
this despite the fact that like Sargon
our our good friend Carl of Swindon his
entire channel vanishes the entire thing
is gone under restricted mode and now
that's actually appropriate because the
man spews hate speech non-stop but he
doesn't care about the fact that he he
disappears in restricted mode because
the people he hates are being hurt by it
and so that's all he really cares about
at the end of the day so as far as I'm
concerned this isn't working it's
working as it's working as intended as
far as he's concerned because it's
hurting the people he wants to hurt so
yeah